we've seen the trick before and uh
hikara will be haunted
by the trick again and uh the whole idea
is that uh
does it work actually let's bring up the
analysis board to check out
whether it works while hikaru i mean i'm
slightly worried he might resign so
if black you mean this pawn yeah if you
take that pawn then i think you can
simply go queen takes queen and then
rook takes and then white will make a
new queen
and that hasn't happened to hikaru
instead threatening checkmate uh by
bringing his rook down he's threatening
to take this pawn with his queen
but magnus that is cynical that is
ruthless just brings his queen up one
square
trading off black's queen blocking any
potential attacks white is threatening
checkmate
and if the queens disappear for example
if the black queen takes this white
queen
then we will just see these two pawns
decide the game these pawns will match
up the board
and it's game over nakamura just resigns
and magnus
yeah look at that he is relieved he's
happy
magnus crawls and saving the
final match